[Music]
hi I'm Kennedy for recent TV and right
now we're going to discuss the July
issue of Reason magazine with reason
magazine editor-in-chief Matt Welch
welcome to your own office thank you
very much appreciate so tell me about
sex in the Arab world it sounds naughty
well we have this great author shareed
al Faqih who has a new book out called
sex in the citadel she was a
correspondent the economist but also she
was involved in HIV research she went
around the arab region and interviewed
people about their most intimate lives
their hopes their dreams their fears and
found a lot of interesting information
that she shared with us at the Museum of
sex love film fittingly laughs in New
York and so this is a transcript of the
conversation that she had about how
after the Arab Spring people are
starting very very slowly to talk about
sex in the Arab world and Mike Riggs has
a great article a kinder gentler drug
prohibition which is about drug courts
supposedly a third way between the war
on drugs and ending prohibition so tell
me about them drug courts were seen as a
way not to have everybody locked up in
prison so they're preferable to that but
they're not some kind of soft treatment
centers that just help you out and then
send you on your way they can be
incredibly restrictive you have to go
two times a week you have to pass drug
tests at odd hours of the night and if
you fail at any step you are back in the
criminal justice system you can be back
in jail or you can be in probation
what Riggs is pointing out is that this
is still prohibition no matter what
you're doing you still have the black
market and all the ills that are
associated with it and it's still very
punitive for people who are in mesh into
that system and it's indicative of the
Obama way of dealing with the war on
drugs which is you know call addiction a
disease but at the same time still use
police and SWAT yes Obama wants to say
that he's not fighting the war on drugs
only because he's not using the
terminology war on drugs but in fact he
has as much spending as much money on
enforcement doing more enforcement than
george w bush on this and no amount of
diversions of drug courts can replace
the fact that this is still prohibition
and it's ruining people's
and you had a great article about one of
my favorite Bruins ever Jackie Robinson
number 42 because of course there's a
lot of attention because of the movie
you found an interesting book you dug up
a book from the early 60s that Jackie
Robinson wrote are we watering down his
legacy I think we are this uh this book
cut called baseball has done it was a
great oral history talking about a lot
of the players and executives of the
previous 20 years came out 64 Jackie
Robinson is widely portrayed as a kind
of Martin Luther King figure so for two
years he heroically endured all these
just horrendous insults by white racists
and fans and everything else but what we
forget is that that only lasted two
years afterwards he did not have to turn
the other cheek anymore and he was a
competitive monster this guy was a
badass he played for sports with
incredible distinction in UCLA he was a
national high jump or long jump champion
he was a scoring leader and what was the
pac-10 or what's called the pac-10 in
basketball all these things he wanted to
find a court in which you didn't have
any advantage as a white person and he
was going to kick the snot out of you
and so I argue that once he was allowed
to stop turning the other cheek he
actually in that five year stretch was
the best baseball player on the planet
that's who he was a viciously
competitive wonderfully competitive
activist he was much more Malcolm X than
he was Martin Luther King and if we're
going to venerate the man so much which
we should let's have the whole
complicated character alright well you
can read about Jackie Robinson drug
prohibition and sex in the Citadel all
of it is in the July issue of Reason
magazine thank you men
you
[Music]